the biden campaign rolls into kenosha
the american psychological association
condemns capitalism and american
institutions
and the atlantic alleges that trump
mocked dead american soldiers i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the bench shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com
okay well actually we begin we can begin
this morning with some actual
good news so the united states did add
1.4 million
jobs in august that means that the
unemployment rate ticked down
to 8.4 percent which it was down like
1.8 percent because it was
it was 10.2 in july so that means that
we are looking at what looks like a
v-shaped recovery it is not in fact
an a u-shaped recovery or a w-shaped
recovery and as the economy continues to
open
you're going to see more and more job
growth which may be one of the reasons
why democrats in many of these states
are a little bit hesitant to open the
economy after all they can blame
bad economic conditions on president
trump if the economy starts to recover
well that may alleviate a lot of the
concerns about president trump's
presidency you see this with joe biden
who is constantly suggesting that
schools are closed because trump botched
covet
that businesses are closed because trump
botched covet well what happens
if new york and new jersey reopen
because it turns out that the virus is
basically dead
there and then the economy starts to
really boom again because it was booming
up until the minute that covet hit well
that would give trump
a pretty strong point going into the
election and you have to suspect that
some of these democratic governors know
this
that they will be blamed politically if
more people die from covet but
they can always blame trump if the
economy continues to be slow because
they are keeping the economy
locked down now the media are trying to
downplay these numbers they're trying to
suggest that the numbers are
disappointing they are not in fact
disappointing the unemployment rate fell
to 8.4 percent down from 14.7
in april and 10.2 in july the drop
according to the new york times brings
the rate below the peak of the last
recession a decade
ago when unemployment briefly hit 10
percent joblessness is still higher than
the peak of many
past recessions of course the figure for
august job growth was buoyed by the
hiring of close to 240 000 temporary
workers for the 2020 census most of whom
will be laid off when the census
canvassing ends
later this month private sector payrolls
which were not affected by the census
rose by 1 million in august
down from 1.5 million in july so it
seems to be slowing a little bit but
that's again because the reopening
has been slowed i mean new york city
still says that they're not going to
open any of the restaurants
like pretty much ever even though there
are zero cases of death
in manhattan from covid right now which
again suggests that this is far more
political
a few podcasts ago i went through all
the unemployment stats and how it
matches up with the lockdown stats
bottom line is this the more you lock
down your state the worse your
unemployment numbers so california has
really bad unemployment numbers new york
has really bad unemployment numbers new
jersey has really bad unemployment
numbers
texas not so much florida not so much
arizona not so much and if you look in
the midwest
the unemployment numbers actually still
look fairly decent this is all a result
of lockdown politics and again lockdown
policy is bad there is no evidence
that lockdown to actually prevent people
from dying of covet all they do
is slow the spread a little bit and then
when you reopen
then the spread increases again which
again
was what lockdowns were designed to do
in the first place lockdowns were
designed to flatten the curve
florida locked down and then florida
released the lockdown and they did so in
safe fashion
and then the curve rose and then the
curve fell again and at no point did
florida system get overwhelmed same
thing with texas
that's what lockdown was supposed to do
right i mean that's what slow the spread
was all about
but now we are told that we have to lock
down until the end of time apparently
one thing i'm deeply fearful of with
regard to covid honestly is that
things will get better and the media
will just fail to report it because the
media have a real
invested interest at this point in
suggesting
that things are not getting better with
covid yesterday on the program i had on
dr marty makari from
johns hopkins university and he was
talking about the development of
monoclonal antibodies so basically the
artificial development
of antibodies that you can take and can
be used as treatment for people
who actually come down with covid it's a
therapeutic it's not a vaccine
his suggestion was that by the end of
this month or the beginning of next
month that there could be solid studies
on monoclonal antibodies such that they
become
a course of treatment for covet that
could theoretically bring the death
rates down below the flu
the question is going to be whether that
is even allowed to be reported remember
throughout this pandemic if at any point
you make any comparison between covet
and the flu even to suggest
that for young people the flu is more
deadly than coveted which it is right if
you're under the age of 20 flu is
significantly more deadly than covet
if you say that then people will suggest
that you're down playing covid
and the media will try to brow beat you
into silence about all of that
even if you're being perfectly accurate
about the data even if you say
that it's more deadly covetous than the
flu for people between the ages of 20
and death essentially
but it's not particularly deadly for
people under the age of 20 and it's not
particularly deadly for people who are
young and healthy which is again true
people will suggest that you're down
playing the impact of the virus so what
happens if it turns out that the medical
community comes up with therapeutics
that are actually quite effective absent
vaccine
such that we can all get back to work
and then the media suggests that things
are still
just as bad as ever i mean the alarmism
that is now going around about what's
going to happen post labor day
is is pretty impressive from the media
they're saying oh there's going to be
this massive second wave after labor day
again we've seen massive
rallies in the streets for months on end
in former hot spots like new york
and new jersey and washington dc and the
cases of hospitalization
and death have not really increased all
that much and the reason for that is
because where it burned through the
virus basically has burned through what
we are seeing
there there's yet to be evidence of a
second wave anywhere what we are
watching is first waves that are hitting
particular communities
right if there's a community that was
locked down and then it opens
then there is a wave right as as the
virus moves into a community with
basically fresh blood
then people die in that community people
get hospitalized and die if you don't
protect the elderly and the vulnerable
if however you're talking about areas
where the virus has already moved
through you're not seeing an uptick in
those areas
in italy northern italy got hit real
hard northern italy is fine now southern
italy is seeing a wave
right now in the uk you're seeing in
increasing cases but it's mostly among
young and healthy populations
is that supposed to be a disaster area
or something so bottom line is this
there may be in fact be a political
interest for politicians in keeping the
lockdowns going
if you particularly if you're a democrat
but there's no reason to continue
these lockdowns particularly in a lot of
the democratic areas that originally
hard hit
in the first place they should have to
make an affirmative case why they need
to continue to lock down
when the virus is not particularly
affecting their communities this is
particularly true again
in new york new jersey massachusetts
washington dc
and uh and other heavily democratic
areas okay we're going to get to
joe biden going to kenosha because this
is the uh the campaign is now
all about how both campaigns are
responding to racial questions and
we'll get to biden and kenosha it was
not a good appearance by joe biden in
kenosha the media pretended it was i
mean
the media bias is is extraordinary in
this election cycle
worse than i've ever seen it i remember
the obama years i remember when they
just
walked around carrying a drool cup for
obama and now they actually are
physically carrying an actual drool cup
for joe biden to drool into if you're
the media it's pretty imp
it's pretty impressive we'll get to that
in just one moment first let us talk
about the best way to watch tv so the
fact is
if you have cable tv because you want
fox news or something you're spending
way too much money for your cable
package like a lot too much money for
your cable package
this is why you need fubo tv football tv
is how you should be watching tv you get
everything you want all in one place for
less than the cost of cable
football tv will bring you over 100
channels cloud tvr
no hidden fees you can stream your
favorite shows on your tv or any other
smart device you can do it to your phone
they have the major broadcasting cable
networks so you can find all your shows
including live sports news
and prime time tv with fubo tv you get
all of your favorite network shows
whether it's this is us or the bachelor
you also get the premier league or the
nba yet all your sports that you could
possibly want and
the news channels you get fox news on
there as well there is no risk to try it
out get full access to fubotv for seven
days
for free a few years ago before
streaming was ubiquitous it made some
sense to subscribe
to cable but i mean it's time for you to
cut the cord and get all the channels
that you could possibly want
through fubotv right now fubotv is
offering our listeners the seven day
free trial and 15 percent off your first
month by going to fubotv.com there are
no contracts you can cancel anytime
you're gonna save a bundle
over what you'd be paying for cable my
parents have already worked on cutting
the cord and going to fubo tv because
honestly it's got all the channels they
need and why do they need to pay for a
bunch of channels they are not watching
instead they've got fubo tv go to
fubotv.com ben for 15 off your first
month
and a free trial that is fubotv.com ben
once more
fubotv.com ben fubo tv.com slash man go
check it out
right now okay so meanwhile joe biden
heads over to kenosha
if the biden campaign is deprived of the
coveted talking point if it turns out
that coveted wayne's if it turns out
therapeutics
are brought about if it turns out that
the number one issue on americans minds
is not in fact covet and if it turns out
that it may be the economy and the
economy starts to boom again then
biden's in real trouble right we are
back to where we were
back in february or march before the
covet pandemic hit and the lockdowns hit
in which case trump was basically
favored by nearly all the betting
markets to win re-election
and that means that joe biden has to
find an alternative case and the
alternative case is that trump is a very
bad mean man who can't unify the country
and that means that joe biden really
does have to focus on the stuff he has
not really wanted to focus on so much
namely the questions of race and racial
unity
like he has said he wants to focus on
that but he really doesn't most of the
democratic platform
most of the dnc was about trump as a
character most of it was about trump not
being a unifying figure but mostly
it was about how trump had blown covet
because he couldn't really make the case
on the economy hard to make the case it
was trump's fault the economy tanked
after a global pandemic
that by the way the u.s responded to
with more alacrity than nearly any other
western country
the united states experienced like a 10
gdp drop in q2
that was better than virtually every
other western country the only one that
was even competitively close was germany
so the united states actually handled
that kind of well i mean like
as well as could possibly be imagined
under the circumstances given how hard
the united states was hit by covet
in the first place so that talking point
may be deprived of joe biden
he may not have the economic talking
point he may not even have the covet
talking point because
again the fact of the matter is this
thing has wiped through most of the
populated areas of the united states now
you're starting to see
the uptick in places like iowa and south
dakota which is what you would expect
again untouched areas will eventually be
touched i mean even new zealand which is
an island in the middle of nowhere with
seven people and
two thousand sheep even that place has
been hit again
okay so that means that joe biden has to
focus in on the i'm a unifying
lightbringer and that's a hard pitch
it's a hard pitch mainly because he was
part of an administration that was quite
divisive
if you look at the racial numbers in
2008 americans were very hopeful about
race relations in
the united states by the time by the
time donald trump took office
in 2017 americans were really not
particularly hopeful about race
relations in the united states
that did not have to do with trump that
had to do with barack obama being an
incredibly polarizing president
after basically pledging that he was
going to be the great racial unifier in
the united states right now red states
no blue states just the united states no
black americans no white americans just
americans right the basic idea of the
obama candidacy was not the idea of the
obama presidency and joe biden was
complicit in that in 2012
he was campaigning on mitt romney the
most milktoast candidate of all time in
all of human history
being somebody who wanted to put you all
back in chains so let's not pretend that
joe biden's racial
game playing is restricted to donald
trump it is not so now joe biden is
trying to
revivify the the race the race relations
card
against donald trump and that means that
he started off yesterday put out this ad
that i commented upon because the ad is
particularly egregious it promotes an
extraordinarily
untrue and also negative message for
black americans
here was joe biden's ad about race
relations in the united states
why in this nation and black americans
wake up knowing that they can lose their
life
in the course of just living their life
part of the point of freedom is to be
free
from brutality from injustice from
racism
and all of its manifestations we have to
let people know
that we not only understand their
struggle but they understand the fact
they deserve to be treated with dignity
they've got to know that the key to this
ad is the first line that joe biden says
right so joe biden says
why in this nation do black americans
wake up knowing they could lose their
life in the course of just living their
life
that is an insane contention i mean
fully crazy there is there is
no evidence that is the case there are
42 million
black americans 42 million of them the
median household income for black
americans about 41
000 a year the average household income
which is which is different than the
median because it's skewed upward by
high incomes like beyonce and jay-z for
example
that's 58 000 a year the the basic
concept that black americans wake up in
the united states fearing for their
lives every day is nuts so first of all
i don't see the poll data on that that
black americans wake up every day
thinking they're going to get shot and
killed
and if they do think that then that is
not true so there are two questions to
be asked one do black americans
think that and two is there any
justification for them thinking that
first of all i don't see tons of
evidence that every black american 42
million of them wake up in deadly fear
of being black in the united states
every day
i do see a media narrative that
promulgates this i do see prominent
people
from black and white saying this kind of
stuff but that raises the second
question
is that feeling justified and the answer
is in an obvious no
obviously black americans should not
wake up in the united states feeling
that they are on the verge of murder
42 million of them that that is that is
great i mean
that's really that's not okay that is a
nuts that is an unjustifiable feeling it
is an unjustifiable feeling
if jews who are the number one targeted
group in the united states in terms of
hate crimes
say that they wake up every morning in
fear that they are going to be
victimized in the united states because
the united states is systemically
anti-semitic
that would be a crazy crazy thing to say
because again even though jews are the
most victimized subgroup in the united
states by hate crimes the united states
is an extraordinarily friendly country
to jews
it's an extraordinarily friendly country
to jews and let's be straight about this
if there were an ad cut by the trump
campaign saying jews wake up every
morning in the united states
afraid of the predations of anti-semites
and then it had like ilhan omar and
rashida talib and all of this
then the media fact-checkers would be
like okay number one did you actually
feel that way and two
would jews be justified in feeling that
way given the fact that jews have an
incredibly high level of education
and they are a very wealthy subgroup and
the fact that very few jews are murdered
okay here are the actual stats on murder
in the united states
again joe biden suggested that black
americans wake up knowing they could
lose their life in the course of just
living their life right this is joe
biden's contention
as of 2013 according to reuters if
you're a black person your chances of
being killed by anyone
by anyone right this is not just cops
your chance of being killed by anyone
again
vast majority of black people who are
killed are killed by other black people
the vast majority of white people who
are killed are killed by other white
people
intra group murder is the most common
cause of murder inter-group murder is
actually fairly uncommon
if you're a black person your chance of
being killed by anyone as of 2013
or 62 per million per million
right six per 100 thousand your chances
of being murdered by a white person
were five per million five per million
okay according to the washington post
database of police shootings
14 black americans were shot while
unarmed by the police in 2019
14 which amounts to a rate of 3 per 10
million
3 per 10 million one per 3.333 million
that is the rate of being shot unarmed
by the cops so if you wake up
in the like is there any person in
america who wakes up thinking about
their one in
3.4 million chance they're 1.3.3
one in 3.3 million chance of dying that
day no one thinks that way
no one does risk assessment that way but
because the media have blown up
every racial narrative in the country to
extraordinary proportions
that's the real reason so if if a lot of
black americans feel like they're on the
verge of murder in the united states
that is solely due to media malfeasance
that is not due to any statistical
reality at all
now in a normal world what we would do
is we would say okay the media
malfeasance should stop
because this is actually really really
damaging stuff how harmful is it for 42
million
let's assume that what biden says is
true how harmful is it for 42 million
americans from 13
of the entire american population to
believe that they live on the verge of
being murdered by the other 87 percent
of the population
every day how damaging is that to
children
who believe that they are waking up in a
country where they could be murdered for
their skin color alone
how damaging is that particularly if
it's not true it's a really damaging
thing and not only is it damaging to
black americans to believe that they are
falsely believe that they're living in a
country that seeks to persecute them and
harm them
it is damaging to the entire body
politic because either you agree with
that in which case you want to wreck all
the systems that have provided american
prosperity security and freedom
or you disagree with it in which case
presumably you are labeled unempathetic
and uncaring which is why i
honestly so i tweeted out what is the
evidence that black americans all 42
million of them wake up knowing they
could be murdered just for being black
what is the evidence to justify this
proposition
this led catherine watson who's a white
house reporter for cbs news
a white house reporter to tweet maybe
white people should sit this one out
she's literally a reporter her job is to
journalism that is some
epic journalism right there now as a
journalist wouldn't you want to ask
whether a proposition is true if a
political candidate for president is
making it
wouldn't you want to ask whether it is
true that black americans fear on a
daily basis being murdered for their
race
or whether that is a justified feeling i
mean isn't that your actual job
but according to katherine watson you
literally should not report
on this you shouldn't fact check
anything that joe biden says
by the way there's a great irony to this
because maybe white people should sit
this one out i noticed joe biden's kind
of white didn't you
joe biden a little bit white so she's
fine with joe biden spouting nonsense
she's fine with joe biden promulgating a
narrative that is incredibly damaging to
the united states and to black americans
in the united states
because he's a white person saying the
right kinds of things
so it really isn't about the race of the
person asking the question
it's really about the question itself
and this
is going to lead to an impasse in
american politics and an impasse in
american life
we'll get to that impasse in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that
you know you really never think about
your phone you bring it into the
bathroom and
you kind of you're you're on the phone
while you're going to the bathroom or
just walking around your daily life
you're touching things then you touch
your phone then you put it to your face
you really really need to make sure
these days particularly that your phone
is sanitized whatever you touch on the
phone that gets past your hands it can
touch your face gets touched your ear
okay you got to clean your phone and
this is why you need phone soap
phone soap is the original patented and
clinically proven uvc
phone sanitizer they've been making
phone sanitizer for the past decade
phone soap uses uvc light and their
patented clinically proven technology to
kill 99.99
of germs like e coli salmonella and the
cold and flu virus
by the way there's a big difference
between there's some people who will say
that they
sanitize like 99 of germs on some parts
of your phone
but phone soap surrounds the entire
phone with the uv light so they achieve
99.99
disinfection which means they're killing
basically a hundred times more bacteria
than just 99
because it's a factorial phone soap can
sanitize and charge your phone in as
little as five minutes
phone soap is the only consumer uv
sanitizer with a 360 degree disinfectant
chamber it uses two pieces of quartz
glass which is important
to suspend your phone making sure that
all sides are disinfected was featured
on shark tank you may have seen it there
for a limited time go to phonesoap.com
and use the code shapiro to say 15
and receive free shipping i mean these
days you don't want the germs on your
phone that is a vector for transmission
of disease
phone soap offers a lifetime warranty on
their bulbs go to phonesoap.com remember
to use the code shapiro that is
phoneshop.com today
phonesoap.com remember to use the code
shapiro and save 15
off and free shipping okay so when joe
biden makes the claim that 42 million
black americans are living an abstract
fear of being murdered in the united
states just killed going about their
daily business
in the united states we should ask
number one whether black americans
really feel that way and
two you do have to ask the question
whether even if people feel a thing
that feeling is justified you know when
it comes to individuals
they're individuals who have depression
uh or a perception of victimhood
it used to be that a school of
psychology suggested that you were there
to reinforce
right you were you were there to have
them tell you the freudian stories about
their childhood that made them think
this way and all of this
and then there came something in
psychology called cognitive behavioral
therapy
and this is something that jonathan
height and greg lukianov have talked
about jonathan height of course the
sociologist from nyu
cognitive behavioral therapy is the
basic idea that you come in
and you complain that something bad is
happening in your life you're really
depressed about it
and what the therapist does instead of
just legitimizing your feelings
you lie on the couch and you do talk
therapy instead of that the therapist
will say
is it possible you're misinterpreting
that is it possible that you are taking
a situation and misinterpreting it the
whole goal is to intervene in your own
thought process
so that you stop being depressed because
instead of you just talking about your
oppression which actually makes you more
depressed and your victimology which
makes you more victimized
instead the question is maybe you've
misinterpreted that or maybe there's a
way around that
or maybe you should stop your thought
process in the middle right is cognitive
behavioral therapy intervening into the
thought process
to stop this chain of thoughts to break
the chain of thoughts that leads to
depression
and leads to malaise and leads to you
know all the things that you don't want
in your life
if you want to be an empowered human
being you can't think
like that you can't think like a victim
you cannot particularly if the evidence
doesn't justify it
so asking whether the evidence justifies
the contention that black americans are
being ground under the hill every day
the grinding
the grinding racism of american life you
have to ask
whether there's material basis for that
and everybody should ask that question
about their own life too
okay this is true on ev for every
individual of every race if you walk
around in your life thinking i am
victimized you have to ask
by whom and how can that be solved or is
it possible that i am misinterpreting
things
or is it possible that everybody has
obstacles in their life and we just have
to overcome
those obstacles the beauty however
politically speaking of blaming a system
is that you never have to look to your
own individual action responsibility
never falls upon you
instead responsibility falls on the
system writ large and we have now
created
via identity politics a system for for
barring the question itself
and that tweet from katherine watson is
so telling right you're not supposed to
ask the question
you're not if you're white you're not
supposed to ask the question
at all right you're not supposed to talk
at all unless you're asking the kind of
question that catherine watson
wants you to ask you're never supposed
to engage in this sort of therapy
because
the only people who can who can think
about whether they truly
have a reason to feel victimized are the
people who feel that
okay but that is not a way to achieve
any sort of political end that locks all
of us in our little individual boxes
unable to communicate with one another
it's the opposite of empathy
and the idea here is that empathy is
putting yourself in somebody else's
shoes
but if you were to put yourself in
somebody else's shoes you would have to
think okay well do they feel justified
in this feeling and if so how do they
make their life better
you wouldn't just sit there and and
wallow in
in whatever it is that you were feeling
under any circumstances
right that is not empathetic that
doesn't solve any problems
but the goal is not to solve the problem
of course the goal is specifically to
suggest that the system is broken
and therefore just give joe biden power
and everything will be all better
and americans fall for this i saw a poll
yesterday that suggested that americans
trust in government is now at all time
loans only only 10
of americans trust the government and i
asked a pretty simple question
so why do you keep giving power to it
all of you right left center why do you
keep giving more power to government if
you don't trust the government
and the answer is that everybody seems
to have bought into the idea that only
the politicians can solve
the systems are broken it is it is not
decisions that are up to us it's not the
stuff we do in our everyday lives that
matters it is the systems that are
broken and therefore it requires quote
unquote systemic solutions
implemented by the top that is a fool's
errand you are not going to get what you
want from joe biden you're not gonna get
what you want from donald trump
it is not only they can fix only you can
fix only you can fix
most of the problems in your life are
solvable by you
and if they are not solvable by you if
somebody is actively discriminating
against you that is illegal and we
should all fight that
if somebody is engaging in actual
illegal activity we should spot that but
instead
we have decided on a narrative whereby
you say you suggest that
wide swaths of people have feelings and
then you can't fact check the
justification for those feelings because
if you do you are therefore uncaring
when precisely the opposite is true
allowing people
to to be stuck in an unjustified feeling
does not help them
it does not make them better it does not
make their lives better and a media that
actively promulgates feelings
that are unjustified is doing something
wrong is doing something bad for country
for the country and doing something bad
for individuals and that's exactly what
joe biden and the media are pursuing
it's really not good stuff
okay so as we'll talk about in a second
joe biden headed over to kenosha
and he met with jacob lake's family and
got on the phone with jacob lake this is
insane to me
i'll explain to you why this is insane
to me in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that things
are uh unsettled right now to say the
least
gun sales are at an all-time high
there's a reason for that people are
feeling rather unprotected
and that is because there has in fact
been a major uptick in crime in most
major american cities
and you look on the tv and then you see
that kenosha is burning and you think to
yourself
you know i i don't really have a lot of
trust that the authorities are always
going to be able to protect me
but it's more than just owning a gun you
got to know how to use it it is very
important for you as a law-abiding
american to be able to protect yourself
and protect your rights but
you also have to know what you can
legally do with a gun you need the
proper education
industry-leading training to ensure your
skills are sharp when faced with danger
and the nation's best legal protection
should you god forbid find yourself
lost in the aftermath of a self-defense
incident this is why you need my friends
at the u.s
concealed carry association the uscca
get started today by texting gun to
you'll receive the complete concealed
carry and family defense guide for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting seven firearm
drills that could save your life and
much much more it's 164 pages and comes
the bonus audio version so you can
listen whenever you want
again it's important for all responsible
americans to responsibly own
firearms and that means you need to know
what you can do what you can't do
and how to protect yourself in addition
if you text today you'll be entered to
win a thousand bucks to put toward a gun
of your choice that you can use to
protect your family
text gun at gun to 87 222 right now get
involved with uscca
and get their concealed carry and family
defense guide for free
again text gun to 87 222 right now to
get started okay so joe biden heads over
to kenosha
and in heading over to kenosha he meets
not with local business owners because
that's what trump did right he met with
the people who were actually victimized
in kenosha when i say actually
victimized
i am specifically saying there is no
evidence to suggest that jacob blake was
quote unquote victimized by the police
okay there the evidence does not suggest
that the evidence suggests that jacob
blake
there was an open warrant for sexual
assault and domestic abuse he was
the cops were called to the scene
because jacob blake was allegedly
digitally raping a woman with her child
in the room
okay and she called the cops and
apparently he did this to her like every
six months according to her allegations
and the cops showed up and then he
resisted arrest he was hazed twice
he shrugged off the cops he walked
around to the driver's side of the car
they had their guns drawn they were
ordering him to comply he did not
he reached into the car and then they
found a knife on the floorboard of the
driver's side of the car and they shot
him
okay that is what is called a justified
shoot by any legal definition
okay if that's unless there is some news
breaking that is called a justified
shooting
it doesn't matter to joe biden though
because again the narrative must be
but the narrative must prevail and the
narrative is that black people are
willy-nilly being murdered in the
streets by police officers
that 42 million black americans should
live their life they are justified
in believing that they should live their
life in abject fear of a system that is
out to get them
the the evidence that i have seen is
that jacob blake the man who was shot
is a bad human being the reason i say he
is a bad human being is because i do not
think that good human beings digitally
rape women in front of their children
okay just just a wild theory i have so
the the fact that he's calling
a guy who's allegedly a a rapist
okay who had three children in the back
of the car he like left his kids in the
car
and then went into this woman's house to
digitally rape her allegedly
that does not sound like the kind of
person a presidential candidate should
get on the phone with nor does it sound
like
he should really be in the house with
the parents of this person
because again there is no evidence that
the cops were unjustified in the
shooting at this point
it doesn't matter to joe biden he says
they should be tried anyway right he
says they should be
they should be charged anyway legal
expert joe biden
he met with the parents of jacob blake
who by the way the father is apparently
a rabid anti-semite
like posted just repeated anti-semitism
in the democratic party is no biggie so
we all understand that right the guy
posted
allegiance to louis farrakhan and and he
was posting all sorts of stuff about how
the jews control the world and all this
kind of stuff
really seems like a charming family joe
biden met with them did not meet with
business owners
and he spoke with jacob blake by phone
for 15 minutes and biden said he talked
about how nothing was going to defeat
him how whether he walked again or not
he was not going to give up
not going to give up on what exactly
like nobody wants people not to be able
to walk this guy
is going to go to jail okay he's gonna
go to jail and he should go to jail if
he
committed the crimes which have been
alleged against him
okay so this in and of itself
demonstrates that the facts do not match
the narrative
but the narrative matters most of all
okay so joe biden then goes to a church
and his visit to kenosha not only was it
you know bad on the messaging front
but also he just looked terrible because
he heads out to kenosha
and it reinforces all of the rumors
about his health it reinforces the fact
that he does not look like he is strong
out there first he suggests
that it is the first chance in a
generation to cut a slice off
institutional racism again
these these words mean nothing
understand that when people say
institutional racism most of the time
they don't know what they are referring
to the term institutional racism was
coined by stokely carmichael the former
head of the black panther party and was
specifically designed to shift the
definition of racism from what we all
understand racism to be
namely the belief in the inferiority or
superiority of a particular group of
people based on their race it shifted
that definition into
any system that creates inequality is
racist which is
which is a an illogical and
evidence-free system
of identifying racism because literally
every system provides for inequality
between groups there is no system that
has no inequality between groups
it does not exist unless you're talking
about a system that provides only abject
poverty for everyone
okay but joe biden is saying mushmouth
crazy words
right he says this is the first chance
in a generation to cut a slice off
institutional racism there's so many
contradictions here first of all i don't
know what the hell he means second of
all
wasn't he vice president like four years
ago what
why wasn't that in operation why wasn't
that an opportunity to cut a slice off
institutional racism hasn't he been in
government
his entire adult life didn't he enter
congress did he answer the senate at age
right and he's now 97 years old so why
isn't
like what is he like this is i'm sorry
this is so evidence-free and so contrary
to any shred any iota of logic that it
boggles the mind here's joe biden saying
a silly thing
this is the first chance we've had in
a generation in my view to deal
and cut another slice off institutional
racism
toward getting the place where it
changes
and by the way the main reason why i'm
optimistic
because of your generation black white
hispanic and asian american
did you ever think you'd turn on tv
you're much younger than i am but you're
the lower than she is you ever think you
turn on the tv
and roughly two out of three ads would
be biracial couples selling a product
um what what what in the world is this
what is this old coot talking about i
mean really what is this old coot
talking about did i ever turn on the tv
and think that we'd see
the middle of melrose avenue shut down
by antifa well
people in the media cheer i didn't think
that okay but
the real story of biden's visit to
kenosha after all was the fact that he's
a daughtering old fool
i mean he he just is i'm sorry he says
silly things all the time
it is completely ignored how bad was
this apparently the questioners here
were being handed scripts
not kidding okay i'm not alleging this
one of the questioners is alleging this
so here's a young woman from kenosha
young black woman from kenosha
and she literally gets up and she says i
was told to read from this piece of
paper but i'm going to ask you an actual
question
who gave her a piece of paper and told
her to read from a piece of paper to joe
biden
i mean joe biden was pretty much reading
from a script the entire time because
he cannot be allowed off the script no
wonder nancy pelosi doesn't want him to
debate trump
here's this woman basically letting the
cat out of the bag here i'm just going
to be honest mr button i was told to go
off this paper but i can't
you need the truth and i'm part of the
truth
i was born here raised here
first eighth grade class of the school
that was named after his mother
so i have to give you the truth of the
people
and the truth of the matter is we are
heavily angry okay so the fact that that
he's being he's handing people scripts
to read him
wow wow and you can see why because here
are some more of the
the wonderful moments from this kenosha
visit so joe biden
is talking about his tax plan and he
literally stops
while speaking in kenosha remember this
whole thing was led off by a media
report about jacob like being shot
he literally stops in the middle of
explaining his tax plan and says they'll
shoot me
not a great look here old joe
19 corporations
making a billion dollars a piece don't
pay a single penny in taxes
i'm not trying to punish anybody but
everyone should pay a fair share
and i can lay out for i won't now
because they'll shoot me but here's the
deal
i pay for every single thing i'm
proposing without raising your
taxes one penny if you make less than
400 grand you're not going to get a
penny tax
and you're going to get a tax cut if you
make under 125 000
okay that that's not true actually but
it doesn't matter the bottom line is
saying
they'll shoot me if i talk about my tax
plan and kenosha is awkward
and then he tells a young man to sit
down because you're getting too antsy
i mean crotchety old coot joe biden here
don't worry guys he's perfectly stable
the most at-risk generation for the
first time in american history
is the z generation they have the
greatest degree of anxiety of any
generation
all the way up the scale no matter where
they are we've also learned and i'll end
with this i know you're getting too
antsy sit down man all right okay
i don't know
here's the deal young whippersnapper is
getting getting getting here's the deal
he don't go over snapper it's getting
too nancy
okay and then joe biden teaches us
history and honestly he should know the
history better than this because he was
around when the light bulb was invented
he actually interned in thomas edison's
office apparently but here is joe biden
radically botching american history
because again
he is not good at this at all people
fear that's what
that which is different we gotta for
example
why in god's name don't we teach
history in history classes
a black man invented the light bulb not
a white guy named edison
okay there's so much did anybody know
before
wait what what's the recently happened
uh no that's not true
i mean i'm i'm sorry but that's not i
mean thomas edison didn't invent the
light bulb louis latimer is the person
he's talking about and he perfected the
carbon filament which is an important
thing but you don't have to be like
thomas edison didn't exist it was used a
figment of our imagination
it was actually a black man who invented
the light bulb wasn't it like enough
like the carbon filament's pretty
important they were using what platinum
filaments before that which would have
been super duper expensive
tungsten so that's that's like an
important thing i feel like that's
important enough you don't have to
rewrite the history
but joe biden is a cr he also just in
the middle of this thing he's like what
am i doing now
he's doddering around the stage but wait
till you see the media reaction to this
because basically of an old white man
who spent his entire career doing
nothing like honestly if he wants to
talk
about at a certain point he's like we
should talk about black contributions to
white american life if he wants to talk
about black contributions to white
american life he is example
1a of a white man who's benefited from a
black man okay
joe biden would be an obscure no-name
ridiculous
much-mocked senator from delaware if it
were not for the fact that joe biden
plucked
that barack obama plucked him from
obscurity and made him his vp would this
guy be a presidential can are you
kidding me had run like 83 times in the
past and it couldn't get more than two
and a half votes
and they were all members of his family
here was joe biden
literally asking what is going on around
him in kenosha
yeah you just stay right here we're
gonna have everyone turn around in the
queue
yes sir what am i doing is elder abuse
at this point
okay wait until you hear the media
drooling all over this the media have
just become
the the public relations wing of the
democratic party because their reaction
to this really
pretty bad kenosha visit is astonishing
astonishing
and it continues to promulgate the dual
narratives that joe biden is good at
this and second that black americans
ought to be living in fear of their
lives all 42 million of them ought to be
living in fear of their lives because of
the predations
of white america we'll get some more of
this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that there are
a thousand reasons why you'd want to
protect your home
right now here in la we have a bit of a
crime spree going on where people
go to people's mailboxes and they just
steal packages right out of the mailbox
well you got ring you can tell exactly
who is doing that you can hand the
information over to the cops i have
several friends who have done this
because they have ring devices i can
tell
who's ringing my doorbell even if i'm
not at home which is important because
sometimes people ring the doorbell
before they rob the joint
because they're casing the plays okay
with ring i can also keep track of my
kids so i have ring cameras all over my
all over my house and that means that my
kids who are basically small suicide
machines they just run around trying to
kill themselves because they're all
under the age of seven and keep track of
them
from my phone wherever i am whatever you
call home ring has everything you need
to protect it
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with video doorbells keep
an eye on every corner of your house
with easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself
and i use ring all the time at my house
like literally all the time because in
my kitchen i have a device
that i have like a tv screen that hooks
up to all my ring cameras got a special
offer on the ring welcome kit at
ringgit.com
it comes that ring video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro that is the perfect way to
start your ring experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com go check them out
right now ring.com ben alrighty it is
that glorious time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily ware member
we have arrived today
is rob valenti on instagram who
understands proper pet care during a
pandemic that is a cute dog my goodness
in the pic a smart little pup is
relaxing next to the world's most elite
beverage vessel
and copies my books the right side of
history and how to destroy america in
three easy steps
the caption reads izzy powering through
the apparently endless lockdown with
some covet 19 home education
while additionally sipping on delicious
and nourishing tears hashtag ben shapiro
hashtag
the daily wire good on you is you got to
stay sharp during these incredible
crazy lockdowns that is a smart and cute
dog my goodness
thanks for the picture rob hope that you
enjoyed the books as well as your dog
also
exciting announcement we're introducing
a new upgraded experience daily wire is
now on apple tv and roku so members can
enjoy all of the visual
magic of this podcast on your big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or roku and download
today
you do have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout and
you'll get 15
off your membership purchase the deal
won't last long so act fast if you want
live shows on your big screen plus
the one of a kind highly coveted much
sought after often imitated never
duplicated leftist year's tumblr
[Music]
again that is dailywire.com shapiro to
get 15 off with codewatch
and download the daily wire on your
apple tv and roku today finally
another announcement for y'all the ben
shapiro show sunday special it's back
and better than ever this week with an
all-new episode featuring candace owens
we'll be talking about the 2020 election
george floyd cardi b tons of other good
stuff so
don't miss out this sunday september 6th
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
[Music]
nation
so the media reaction to joe biden's
kenosha visit was entirely predictable
the drool cups were out not just for
them but also for joe biden because they
have to catch his rule
cnn's brook baldwin i don't know why
she's not if she's not getting paid by
the biden
campaign i don't know why not it seems
like she could earn a lucrative side
salary
simply by acknowledging that she's a
propagandist listen to her reaction to
joe biden doddering around
in a church while apparently handing
like scripted pieces of paper to people
to ask him questions this is
here's brooke baldwin going full jake
harney never go full jay carney
point by point by point on his notes uh
you know just just questions concerns
from from folks there who have been able
to speak up about
you know their children in education and
mental health and the
health and then the prison system but i
want to go back just briefly i mean
obviously he's there in the wake of the
the jacob blake shooting he's met with
the family today
and he was mentioning charlottesville
and again you know when joe biden
announced he wanted to run for president
what did he say he wants to fight for
the soul of this nation
and that is precisely what he is trying
to do in making his case to become
the next president of the united states
now that is precisely what he's doing
well
i mean wow wow she is so impressed she
is so impressed and i never would have
predicted that from a cnn
anchor never would have predicted
anything remotely like that so brook
baldwin doing the heavy lifting there
meanwhile cnn had an entire panel
lionizing jacob blake
and joe biden and then jacob blick's
attorneys were attacking donald trump
and william barr
nothing like having the attorneys for a
man accused
alleged of uh of digitally raping one
with her son in the room
appearing on tv to lionize joe biden
uh and cnn had an entire panel doing
this it was really really solid stuff uh
by the way the lawyer originally claimed
lest you forget benjamin crump
originally claimed
that jacob blake was there on the scene
in order to break up a fight between two
women he was a good samaritan
and then he tried to walk away from the
confrontation when he was senselessly
shot by the cops
not one element of that was true here is
the uh here was that bit of uh
of propaganda on cnn yesterday what
we've seen was
you know vice president biden uh show a
great degree of empathy and that also
shares stories and challenges
of medical challenges that he's
personally had
and i thought that was i thought that
helped ease
um the burden a little bit to some
degree for
jacob what we heard from vice president
biden
is that he is very supportive of
measures
that allow police to better do their job
i think that uh attorney general barr's
statements
um are very disturbing and i think that
type of rhetoric
is divisive and i think at a time where
we really need to be united what was
divisive there okay that guy's actually
blavori lamar
benjamin crump was the person who took
the photo that you see on the screen
there that's why i said benjamin crump
you can see the photo on the screen
of of jacob blake blavory lamar well
what exactly did bar do that was so
terrible barr said that systemic racism
is not a problem in police departments
across the country
which again is true okay the evidence of
systemic racism
meaning that the police are systemically
racist like out to get black people
it is not there the evidence that that
is a widespread problem in american
policing is not there
are there cases of policemen who are
racist sure are there cases of everybody
in
any industry being racist sure are
police
widely and broadly speaking racist and
out to get black people the answer of
course
is no but this is the narrative
promulgated by the media again this all
goes back to that centralized narrative
that democrats and the media have been
pushing
for now decades which is that black
people are being
ground under the boot heel of american
cruelty and racism
now that message immediately goes away
as soon as democrats are elected but
when republicans are in office then it
immediately comes back again what's so
insulting about this is there was a
point in time when this was true
for in fact a huge swath of american
history this was true
it is not true in 2020 it has not been
true for quite a while
nonetheless he was msnbc's eddie cloud
yesterday saying that if you say the
phrase law and order that's bad
because if you say law and order that's
shifting the blame from police brutality
to how black people respond to police
brutality well hold up
if you're responding to false
allegations of police brutality by
burning a city it seems to me that law
order is pretty important
and it turns out the law order is mostly
important for people living
in communities where law and order is
not observed if you're living in a poor
impoverished community what you need
is property rights and individual rights
protected one order should be important
to everyone it is the precondition for a
civilized society but eddie glad says if
you say law and order it's because
you're a racist
when we hear the language of law and
order we need to understand its origin
it has everything to do with
shifting the blame and focus from the
violence of police
to how black people respond to the
violence that they experience
so when we think about all of the urban
unrest in in the 20th century 90 percent
of that urban unrest
uh chris has been a result has been a
response to police violence
90 and so what we do is we respond to
the quote unquote looting and the
violence but we never address the
underlying cause
okay th this is this is so crazy that
you're not allowed to talk about
about law and order because somehow
you're a racist if you mentioned law and
order according to eddie glab
and this narrative again is is
promulgated in every circumstance in
every circumstance regardless of the
surrounding fact pattern
so for example there was a low level
unrest
in washington dc over the last couple of
nights after there was a man named dion
k who was shot
okay he was an 18 year old he was shot
by a dc police officer he died shortly
afterward
in a nearby hospital and then he
immediately became part of the pantheon
of say their name
right protesters sprung into action they
went to uh
the house of dc mayor muriel bowser who
of course had tried to appease the mob
and be part of the mob by painting giant
letters on
on the street and renaming plazas and
all of this so they initially seized on
reports that a black man was
unjustifiably shot by the cops
and then the tape came out and it turns
out that this guy was running
from the cops he was not in fact shot in
the back as the original allegation
suggested he was shot directly in the
front because he was carrying a handgun
at the time
what's the cop supposed to do like stand
there and wait for the suspect to raise
the handgun and shoot him
here is the actual tape of what happened
with dion k
hear the cops arriving if you can't see
this and they are
they are chasing the suspect okay
and then they see the suspect the
suspect comes around the corner and
he uh and he has a gun right and then
they go and they find the gun
and so it looks like maybe he was trying
to throw the gun but you have no idea
when somebody comes to you with a gun
what are you supposed to do wait for it
wait to see like which angle his arm is
going to come at
according to townhall.com police say
officers were responding to a live
stream on social media of a man
brandishing a firearm
the officers recognized the young man
from their previous encounters with the
individual
according to the chief k was a validated
gang member when officers arrived and
approached the car two of the four
occupants
fled on foot body cam footage of the
incident captures dionke raising a gun
as he raises toward
raises as he runs toward a hispanic
officer the officer then fires a single
shot at k
striking him in the chest and two people
who complied with the cops of course
were arrested without injury which is
what typically happens i remember even
in the george floyd situation there were
other people in the car nothing happened
to them
and meanwhile another fact pattern that
is now being uh used as an evidence of
systemic american racism
seven police officers have been
suspended in rochester after the death
of daniel prude we talked about this
case a little bit yesterday
this is a case in which there is a black
man who was apparently high on pcp
and it was suspected that he was
suffocated to death by the officers
according to the new york times the man
daniel prude was having a psychotic
episode
apparently he'd been hospitalized for
suicidal ideation earlier in the day and
then released
he was handcuffed by officers running
naked in the streets in the middle
of a freezing night you can actually see
the snow coming down in the video
prude began spinning and claiming out
loud that he had coveted 19 at the
beginning of the coveted crisis
and then they put what was called a spit
sock over his head those are mesh bags
okay they don't suffocate you they are
mesh bags you can breathe through them
as he when he tried to rise the
officer's force proved face down on the
ground one of them pushes his head to
the pavement
prude was held down by the police for
two minutes and then later had to be
resuscitated
the accusation is of course that they
asphyxiated him
okay now there's one problem with this
the emt
arrives and they're they're focusing in
on the fact that one of the officers
has his knee on the guy's back now that
is throughout the united states an
approved procedure cause this is true
for george floyd too it's an approved
police procedure
dealing with a condition called excited
delirium
hey excited delirium is a medically
known condition and in fact when the emt
arrives on scene when the emt arrives on
scene
the emt says guys this is a case of
excited delirium
right like he's trying to comfort them
he says this isn't your fault now
the media have also said that they're
laughing at him the man makes some sort
of comment about his
about his penis and they start laughing
at the comment because it's kind of
funny
they're not sitting there laughing at
the man's condition okay that's not what
the video actually shows in any case
excited delirium has now been mistaken
in several cases
for police brutality here's an article
from
the western journal of emergency
medicine circa 2011
from professor asia takuchi of the
university of california san diego
school of medicine
terence ahern from the keck school of
medicine at usc and sean henderson from
the keck school of medicine
at usc about excited delirium here is
how they describe the condition of
excited delirium
excited or agitated delirium which again
was
named by the officers in this case also
in the george floyd case is
characterized by agitation aggression
acute distress and sudden death often in
the pre-hospital care setting
it is typically associated with the use
of drugs that alter dopamine processing
hyperthermia and most notably sometimes
with death of the affected person in the
custody of law enforcement
subjects typically die from
cardiopulmonary arrest although the
cause is debated
so in fact what they're saying is that
basically excited delirium happens to a
lot of people but very often
is the reason why the cops are called
because you'll see something somebody
acting
extraordinarily erratically aggressively
you'll see people acting with agitation
it's it's associated with drugs drugs
like for example fentanyl in the case of
george floyd or in this particular case
drugs like pcp hypothermia right
hypothermia is where you're too cold
hyperthermia is where you hot which
might be one reason why this uh why this
unfortunate guy uh was uh was walking
around naked in the snow
subjects typically die from a
cardiopulmonary arrest right they die of
a heart attack essentially
and then people mistakenly attribute
that to the restraints that the officers
are using i mean they literally say this
in a 2011 article these are doctors
right these are medical doctors so
we're following the science here so one
of the things that they say
is ext right excited delirium has gained
increasing public attention recently
due to the number of postmortem
explanations offered by medical
examiners regarding the death of
individuals being restrained by police
or being taken
into custody authors of one review
article found enough evidence in the
literature to suggest that excited
delirium
might represent the clinical spectrum of
a and rhabdomy
rhabdomyolysis and neuroleptic malignant
syndrome might represent the clinical
spectrum of a single
disease they say that very often
medical examiners mistakenly attribute
the deaths to asphyxia in these
particular cases
but in fact in most cases excited
delirium people died with ever having
encountered the police
since the victims sometimes die in
police custody says this study the most
widely
publicized proposed causes of death in
ext are taser use and positional
asphyxia
no study thus far has been able to
demonstrate a causal relationship
between taser use and subsequent
individuals death
also supporters of the positional
asphyxia hypothesis
postulate and that anoxic death results
from the combination of increased oxygen
oxygen demand with a failure to maintain
a patented airway or inhibition
of the chest wall but the positional
asphyxia theory has been refuted by a
series of articles exploring the effect
of prnp on ventalor ventilatory capacity
and arterial blood gases okay so
basically what this
article says is that people suddenly die
after exhibiting excited delirium and it
is generally not
the suppression of the officers that
leads to it but one of the reasons why
this is an approved use of force you
know putting
your knee on somebody's back or on back
of somebody's neck as long as you're not
actually cracking their sternum or
something
is because people get very aggressive
and they get very erratic when they have
excited delirium this has been treated
by everybody as another example of
unwarranted police brutality and if you
know nothing about excited delirium
that's what it looks like
but the media don't even bother to
report on excited delirium which is in
fact what the emc said it was
arriving on scene arriving on scene so
again the narrative matters more
than anything else speaking of the
narrative mattering more than anything
else
yesterday the suspect in portland was
fatally shot by u.s marshals so
the media again they have an agenda to
pursue and the agenda
to pursue is that the violence in
america's major cities is not in fact
caused by antifa or blm supporters it is
caused by right-wingers
so yesterday the suspect in the fatal
shooting of uh
the suspect in the fatal shooting of a
right-wing supporter
in portland was shot and killed by a u.s
marshals task force near lacey on
thursday evening
the uh the shooter is 48 year old
michael forrest rhino
he was the suspect he murdered a man who
was a
patriot prayer guy there was a
warrant out for rhinos arrest earlier on
thursday
and uh apparently the suspect came out
of the car he was carrying a gun
he apparently fired shots at the
officers
and uh they uh and then they shot him so
he was pronounced dead at the scene
now earlier in the day vice found the
guy and they interviewed him
and they simply allowed him to
propagandize about how he was actually
attempting to
lower the temperature and how he how he
shot this man in self-defense there's no
evidence that he shot the man in
self-defense i mean the evidence is
pretty clear in fact on tape that he's
just a patent murderer
here was the suspect this is uh
obviously before being shot
lots of lawyers suggest that i shouldn't
even be saying anything but i feel it's
important that
the world at least gets a little bit of
what's really going on because there's
been a lot of propaganda put out there
i had no choice i mean i i had a choice
i could have sat there and watched them
kill a friend of mine of color
but i wasn't gonna do that there's no
evidence that the man who was shot was
about to kill
a person of color none okay so then this
guy apparently he has a rifle and he
gets into some sort of gun battle
with the cops and then he gets shot i
need to read you how the new york times
characterizes this
because it is incredible it is
incredible this guy is
an antifa member he characterized
himself as 100 antifa
who had been arrested prior on a gun
violation like in early july
he was let off with no charges in
multnomah county and then he went
murdered somebody here's how the new
york times reported this story
quote suspect in fatal portland shooting
is killed by officers during arrest
law enforcement agents killed michael
forest reinold while trying to arrest
him for officials said
he was being investigated in the fatal
shooting of a supporter of a far-right
group
so just to be straight in the subhead
there's no mention of antifa there's no
mention of black lives matter
the only political affiliation is the
victim
right the only person whose politics the
new york times cares about apparently is
the victim
it's amazing here's the first here is
the first paragraph law enforcement
agents shot and killed
an antifa supporter on thursday as they
move to arrest him in the fatal shooting
of a right-wing activist who is part of
a pro-trump caravan
in portland oregon officials said the
suspect michael forest rhino 48 was shot
by officers from a federally led
fugitive task force
during the encounter in washington state
okay buried down
further in the interview they went and
they interviewed a bunch of this guy's
friends
and according to this guy's friends he
was a wonderful man
okay here is here is the way that the
new york times reports on his death okay
and again all evidence is that he
murdered somebody in cold blood by
shooting him point blank
okay quote as part of the protesters
security team during the demonstrations
mr reinold's role included intercepting
potential agitators
and helping calm conflicts fellow
protesters said nightly he would break
up fights said randall mccorkle a
regular at the demonstrations who said
he became close friends with rhino as
they wore on
he wanted change so badly he said his
death he said would likely inspire
others to continue the movement for
police reform
i was going to say radicalized but
galvanize is a better word he said
honestly i'm going to try to step into
his shoes rhys monson a local leader
in the protest movement who also helps
organize security set all the people who
helped with security in portland
including reynolds were trained on
de-escalation
he was excellent at that said mr monson
mr monson said security designees have
been trained to approach potential
agitators and politely ask them to leave
they've also been trained on how to
conduct physical removals but are
cautioned to try to avoid such measures
because they can cause situations to
escalate
mr monson said mr reinel would often
come over to discuss how to handle
potential agitators appropriately
he was literally a guardian angel said
teal linseth one of the main organizers
of the portland protest
he would protect you no matter what
early on friday miss linseth
spray-painted a tribute to mr rhino on
the street in front of the police
precinct where demonstrators were
gathered
long-lived mike she wrote the best ally
ever
it is only at this point that the new
york times says you know on july 5th he
was charged with resisting arrest in
possession of a loaded firearm
and uh he showed the end he showed a
bloodied arm to a journalist with
bloomberg and said he'd been shot while
intervening in a fight at the end of
july
i mean it's just it's amazing so then
the new york times just runs cover
for a guy who pretty obviously was a
murderer
and this is your wonderful media the the
narrative has overtaken nearly all of
america's major institutions we're in
the middle
of a cultural revolution it's a cultural
revolution which america's major
institutions ranging from political
parties
to media outlets to even places like the
apa
have uh had the american psychological
association have been overtaken
by politics and and it undermines their
credibility as experts by
the way i'm not going to listen to the
quote unquote experts unless they
actually demonstrate expertise in the
subject area
that they purport to proclaim expertise
okay the american psychological
association i'm supposed to believe
their designations in the dsm that a man
who believes he is a woman is not in
fact
suffering from any sort of mental
condition or mental illness i'm supposed
to believe that
i'm gonna believe that from the same
people at the apa who now suggests
that capitalism is racist these are the
experts guys
very scientific people super scientific
the president of the american
psychological association
which represents psychologists in the
united states
accused the united states of harboring a
racism pandemic
the president of the association of
black psychologists stated quote every
institution in america
is born from the blood of white
supremacist ideology and capitalism
and that's the disease according to a
press release released by the apa
this is so scientific the experts are
telling you guys we're in the middle of
a racism pandemic and
every institution in america is racist
and so is capitalism
the statements were made by apa
president sandra shulman and abpsi
president ethiopia jackson shulman said
we are living in a racism pandemic which
is taking a heavy psychological toll
on our african-american citizens the
health consequences are dire
racism is associated with a host of
psychological consequences including
depression anxiety and other serious
sometimes debilitating conditions
including post-traumatic stress disorder
and substance use disorders
moreover stress caused by racism can
contribute to the development of
cardiovascular and other physical
diseases research shows that compared
with white's black feel more negative
stereotype threats and more racial
profiling when interacting
with the police so we need to have a
conversation the apa is addressing
these issues okay this is so
anti-scientific it boggles the mind in
their further sources cited that they
cite the garbage book
robin d'angelo's white fragility so the
cultural revolution has now overtaken
quote unquote institutions of science
meanwhile elizabeth warren wants to use
those institutions of science in order
to
use the government to cram down her
purported messages
lauren has now joined forces with
representative ayanna pressley who was
encouraging violence five seconds ago
and representative barbara lee of
california to promote the anti-racism
and public health act
which would put coven 19 restrictions in
the same square as black lives matter at
protests
warren said in a statement it's time we
start treating structural racism
like we would treat any other public
health problem or disease
oh you mean a thing that you can't
define you want to treat like an actual
disease you mean you want to use the
power of the cdc in order to go after
people who you purport to be who you
claim are racist
without any evidence that they're
actually racist because remember
structural racism
does not require racist intent or actual
racist policy
it just requires disparate
so she wants to create a national center
for anti-racism at the centers for
disease control and prevention
to research and explore racism's health
impacts
they also want to create a law
enforcement violence prevention program
at the cdc
as a bulwark against police brutality
because when i think of central for
disease control
first thing i think is law enforcement
violence prevention
program pretty incredible stuff here
from elizabeth warren so all major
institutions
will be turned toward the narrative over
at usc how far have they turned at the
universities toward this narrative
here's how far they've turned
at the universities toward this
narrative over the last couple of days a
man named greg patton a professor of
clinical business communication at usc
was suspended from his job why because
he had this to say he he literally was
talking about how
people use filler words in different
languages and he mentioned
a filler word in chinese okay and um
here is what he had to say this got him
suspended and investigated by the
university of southern california
when people claim they were offended by
a word in chinese that sounds like a
slur in english but has nothing to do
with that slur
if you have a lot of armorers and this
is culturally specific so based on your
native language
like in china the common word is that
that that that
so in china it might be naked so there's
different words that you'll hear in
different countries
but they're vocalists
he was suspended for this usc is now
offering supportive measures to any
student faculty
or staff member who request assistance
the school is quote committed to
building a culture of respect and
dignity where all members of our
community can feel safe
supported and can thrive our
institutions are completely broken
completely and utterly broken all points
of commonality
have been lost and you can tell where
people believe the polls of power are in
american society right now and the
direction of american society
is moving we have another rachel dolezal
case
so there is a woman who is at george
washington university she's an associate
professor in african history her name is
jessica krug
she admitted thursday she's actually a
culturally choice white
she wrote a life-shattering medium post
titled the truth and anti-black violence
of my lies
she's a self-proclaimed historian of
politics ideas and cultural practices in
africa and the african diaspora diaspora
she said for the better part of my adult
life every move i've made
every relationship i've formed has been
rooted in the napalm toxic soil
of lies to an escalating degree over my
adult life i've eschewed my lived
experience
as a white jewish child in suburban
kansas city under various assumed
identities within a blackness that i had
no right to claim
first north african blackness then u.s
rooted blackness then caribbean rooted
bronx blackness
i've built my life on a violent
anti-black lie i've lied in every breath
i have taken she's the author of the
book fugitive modernities kisama and the
politics of freedom which interrogates
the political practices and discourses
through which those who fled from
slavery and the violence of the slave
trade in angola
forged coherent political communities
outside of and in opposition to state
politics
she says there is no parallel form of my
adulthood connected to white people or a
white community or an alternative white
identity
i have lived this life fully completely
with no exit plan or strategy i have no
identity outside of this i have never
developed one so she doesn't really
explain
why she was uh finding uh why she has
decided to reveal this
and now the the actual answer is that
she decided to reveal this apparently
because she was about to be outed
about all of this but again we live in a
society where
you know folks like rachel dolezal seek
positions of power
by masquerading as members of a
particular race and now you have this
woman who is masquerading as a black
woman
in order to gain presumably power and
prestige
that does say something about where we
stand in american society today
there were not a lot of white people who
were who were attempting to pass as
black
in a time of widespread american racism
in the 1950s 1960s 1940s 1930s
okay this is just another cultural
hallmark of the fact that in fact black
americans are treated
really well in the united states again
people don't tend to masquerade and take
on the
the lived experiences of people who are
the victims in a society
that is not something that they tend to
do in fact throughout tragic periods of
american history
black people in many cases were forced
to try to masquerade as white people
simply so they could be treated as equal
human beings
right the the fact that you now have
people in academia
rachel dolezals or this lady who are
trying to act black and pretend to be
black in order to gain cultural prestige
i mean this lady obviously has problems
you don't want to use her as the case in
point of what's going on in the united
states
but again it does have something to say
on a broader level about where we stand
in terms of race relations
in the united states okay now i know
that we're going a little long here but
i'd also be remiss if i did not comment
on um on this story from the atlantic
that claims that president trump said
that americans who died in war are
losers and suckers the reason that we
have to talk about this obviously is
this is becoming
a major democratic narrative so jeffrey
goldberg who's just garbage jeffrey
goldberg is the editor of the atlantic
he was just a mouthpiece for the obama
administration he frequently just
mouthed whatever obama slogans obama
wanted him to mouth
he's terrible i really i think jeffrey
goldberg is is awful in virtually every
way
including the firing of kevin williamson
the conservative columnist he hired him
he assured me to have a job there's some
blow back he fired him because jeffrey
goldberg is a coward so now jeffrey
goldberg has run a piece
suggesting via four anonymous sources
everything that the left would want to
believe about president trump
and so the headline at the atlantic is
trump americans who died in war are
losers and suckers
when president donald trump canceled a
visit to the einmarn american cemetery
near paris in 2018 he blamed rain for
the last minute's decision saying the
helicopter couldn't fly and that the
secret service wouldn't drive him there
neither claim was true trump rejected
the idea of the visit because he feared
his hair would become disheveled in the
rain and because he did not believe it
important to honor american war dead
according to four people with firsthand
knowledge of the discussion in that day
now here's the problem they're on the
record books about this particular
incident
and there are emails specifically
talking about the weather inside the
administration
talking about the weather that day and
why they had to cancel the event
but reports jeffrey goldberg in a
conversation with senior staff members
on the morning of the scheduled visit
trump said why should i go to that
cemetery it's filled with losers
in a separate conversation on the same
trip trump referred to the more than
1800 marines who lost their lives
at billu wood which is a world war one
site as suckers
for getting killed below wood is a
consequential battle in american history
the ground on which it fought is
venerated by the marine corps
america and its allies stopped the
german advance toward paris there in the
spring of 1918 but trump
on that same trip asked aides who are
the good guys in this war he also said
he didn't understand why the united
states would intervene on the side of
the allies
there was no precedent in american
politics for trump's repeated
expression of contempt for service
members
and he talks about how john mc he was
mean to john mccain of course which of
course we already know
and was gross at the time but according
to four different sources
he uh he just craps all over dead
soldiers and
and and soldiers who have been wounded
in the line of duty
according to the atlantic on memorial
day 2017 trump visited arlington
national cemetery a short drive from the
white house he was accompanied on this
visit by john kelly who was then the
secretary of homeland security and who
would a short time later be named white
house chief of staff
the two men were set to visit section 60
the 14-acre area of the cemetery that is
burial ground for those killed in
america's most recent wars
kelly's son robert is buried in section
60. a first lieutenant in the marine
corps
robert kelly was killed in 2010 in
afghanistan he was 29
trump was supposed to join kelly in
paying respects at his sons graves but
according to sources with knowledge of
the visit trump
while standing by the grave turned
directly to his father and said i don't
get it what was in it for them
kelly who declined to comment for the
story initially believed people close to
him said that trump was making a
ham-handed reference to the selflessness
of america's all-volunteer force
but later he came to realize that trump
simply does not understand
non-transactional
life choices he can't fathom the idea of
doing something for someone other than
himself one of kelly's friends a retired
four-star general told me okay so now
it's not even that uh that that kelly uh
that he said something bad to kelly it's
that kelly interpreted in a way that was
bad but didn't go on the record so you
have four sources
saying that he is mean to dead and
wounded soldiers and none of them would
go on the record
none of them go on the record and this
is being used by the democrats
to uh to go after donald trump trump has
denied all of these allegations of
course but it doesn't matter
so long as a source is so long as
there's an unnamed source the media will
believe
anything that confirms their narrative
this is why the michael wolf book became
a bestseller even though apparently was
completely full of crap
the media have fact-checking standards
in which they will go after donald trump
for nearly anything but they won't fact
check themselves or request that anybody
go on the record
if you're gonna make a shocking
allegation like the sitting president of
the united states
goes around calling dead and wounded
american soldiers suckers and losers
uh their high standards from our media
these days
already we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise please i said this every
single friday try not to burn down the
country you guys keep ignoring me and
it's getting worse
and so i'm gonna give you a timeout if
you don't stop this otherwise we'll see
you here on monday i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen